you've seen how the convolution
operation allows you to implement a
vertical edge detector in this video you
learn the difference between positive
and negative edges that is the
difference between light to dark versus
dark to light edge transitions and you
also see other types of edge detectors
as well as how to have an algorithm
learn rather than have us hand coding
edge detector as we've been doing so far
so let's get started here's the example
you saw from a previous video we have
this image six by six test light on the
left and dark on the right and
convolving aware of the vertical edge
detection filter results in detecting
the vertical edge down the middle of the
image what happens if in an image where
the colors have flipped where it is
darker on the left and brighter on the
right so the tins are now on the right
half of the image and the zeros on the
Left if you convolve it with the same
edge detection filter you end up with
negative thirties instead of thirty down
the middle and you can plot that as a
picture that we don't like that so
because the shades of the transitions is
reversed the 30s now gets reversed as
well and negative 30s
shows that this is a dok2 light rather
than the light to dark transition and if
you don't care which of these two cases
it is you could take absolute values of
this hump output matrix but this
particular filter does make a difference
between the light to dark versus the
dolphin light edges let's see some more
examples of edge detection this 3x3
filter we've seen allows you to take
vertical edges so maybe it should not
surprise you too much that this 3x3
filter will allow you to detect
horizontal edges so as a reminder a
vertical edge according to this filter
is a three by three region where the
pixels are relatively bright on the left
part and relatively dark on the right
part so similarly a horizontal edge
would be if the event the region where
the pixels are relative
great on top and relatively dark in the
bottom row so here's one example this is
a more complex one where you have here
tins in the upper left and lower right
hand corner so we draw this as an image
this be an image which is going to be
darker you know where they're zeros
someone's shaded in the darker regions
and then lighter India upper left and
lower right hand corners and if you
convolve this with a horizontal edge
detector you end up with this and so
just to take a couple of examples this
30 here corresponds to this 3x3 region
where indeed there are bright pixels on
top and darker pixels on the bottom it's
kind of over here and so it finds a
strong positive edge there and this
negative 30 here corresponds to this
region which is actually brighter on the
bottom and darker on top so that is a
negative edge in this example and again
as a this is kind of an artifact of the
fact that we're working with relatively
small images you know that this is just
a 6x6 image but decent immediate values
like this minus 10 for example just
reflects the fact that that filter here
it captures part of the positive edge on
the left and part of the negative edge
on the right and so blending those
together gives you something to mediate
value but if this is a very large say a
thousand by thousand image with this
type of you know checkerboard pattern
then you won't see these these
transition regions of the tens the
intermediate values would be quite small
relative to the size of the image so in
summary different filters allow you to
find vertical and horizontal edges it
turns out that the 3 by 3 vertical edge
detection filter reviews is just one
possible choice and historically in the
computer vision literature there was a
fair amount of debate about what is the
best set of numbers to use so here's
something else you could use which is
maybe 1 2 1 0 0 0 minus 1 minus 2 minus
1 this is called a sobel filter and the
advantage of this is it you know puts a
little bit more weight to the central
role the central pixel and this makes it
maybe a little bit more robust but
compute vision researchers will use
other excessive numbers as well like
maybe instead of a 1 to 1 it should be a
3 10 3 right and then minus 3 minus 10
minus 3 and this is called a Shaw filter
and this has yet other slightly
different properties and this is just
for vertical edge detection and if you
flip it 90 degrees you get horizontal
edge detection and with the rise of deep
learning one of the things we learned is
that when you really want to detect
edges in some complicated image maybe
you don't need to have computer vision
researchers handpick these 9 numbers
maybe you can just learn them and treat
the 9 numbers of this matrix as
parameters which you can then learn
using back propagation and the goal is
to learn 9 parameters so that when you
take the image the six by six image and
convolve it with your three by three
filter that this gives you a good H
detector and what you see in later
videos is that by just treating these
nine numbers as parameters you know the
backdrop can choose to learn 1 1 1 or
minus 1 minus 1 over 1 or learn the
sobel filter all varnish a filter or
more likely learn something else that is
even better at capturing the statistics
of your data than any of these hand
coded filters and rather than just
vertical horizontal edges maybe you can
learn to detect edges there at 45
degrees or 70 degrees or 73 degrees or
whatever orientation it chooses and so
by just letting all of these numbers be
parameters and learning them also nicely
from data we find that new networks can
actually learn
low-level features can learn features
such as edges even more robustly
computer researchers are generally able
to code up these things by hand but
underlying all these computations is
still this convolution operation which
allows back propagation to learn
whatever 3x3 filter once and then to
apply it throughout the entire image you
know in this position and this position
at this position in order to output
whatever feature it's trying to detect
the vertical edges horizontal edges or
edges at some of the angle or even some
other filter that we might not even have
a name for in English so the idea that
we treat these numbers as parameters we
learn has been one of the most powerful
ideas in computer vision and later in
this course later this week why she
talked about the details how of how you
actually go about using back propagation
to learn these numbers but first let's
talk about some other details some of
the variations on the basic convolution
operation in the next two videos I want
to discuss with you how to use heading
as well as different strides for
convolutions and these two will become
important pieces of this convolutional
building block of convolutional neural
networks so let's go on to the next
video